être femme c'est pas simplement être
sexuel et jaden façon c'est d'être
craints certaine manière de la société
simone de beauvoir auteur du deuxième
sexe en 1949
le livre qui a nourri des générations de
féministes jugé indécent et immoral à sa
sortie l'ouvragé ne se voulait pas
provocateur
c'était une étude impartiale et très
détaché à ma chance et je n'ai pas les
poussins 10 comme un défi
ce qui fait qu ensuite les réactions
masculine que j'ai eu à ce livre m'ont
souvent complètement stupéfaite
est ce que le biais talent et pas du
tout le deuxième sexe fait malgré tout
partie des textes fondateurs du
féminisme
alors que la cause n'existait pas
formellement en france il a trouvé un
écho particulier aux états unis
c'est si merveilleux de vous avoir ici
dans ma sphère car vous êtes mon héroïne
depuis que j'ai 20 ans le deuxième sexe
a été quelque chose de fantastique car
il disait tout ce que l'on savait
inconsciemment et personne ne l'avait
encore mai 68 la réappropriation du
corps la libération sexuelle la parité
autant de revendications déjà abordé
dans le deuxième sexe le texte connu des
militants parlent désormais à une
génération de femmes
était une bombe une bombe à retardement
qui n'en finit pas d'exploser et qui
explosera encore longtemps parce que le
féminisme est loin d'être acquis
actuellement il ya un retour en arrière
qui montre bien à quel point c'est
toujours aussi virulent donc le deuxième
sexe a été le la fusée de lancement suit
naturellement de grandes figures
françaises du féminisme se réclame de
simone de beauvoir simone de beauvoir à
forcer les femmes à reprendre en main
leur destin
autrement dit elle leur a expliqué par
cette formule lapidaire le biologique
n'est pas suffisant pour déterminer
votre destin vous avez le choix est par
exemple vous pouvez être une femme à
part entière réussi sans être mère le
livre phare de simone de beauvoir et
régulièrement discuté et débattu des
décennies après sa sortie
même si ce livre à 50 ans elle était
tellement en avance sur son temps elle a
eu tellement d'audace dans dans sa
pensée anti naturaliste qu'elle a
vraiment posé des problèmes qui restent
complètement actuelle la question de
l'indépendance de la liberté du corps de
la liberté sexuelle ouvrage émancipateur
en 1949 le deuxième sexe reste
aujourd'hui une bible du féminisme
[Musique]